una crisis energética que se ha
convertido en una crisis de recursos
hídricos esta residente de houston no
tuvo energía en casa durante cuatro días
y ahora se ha quedado sin agua las
gélidas temperaturas provocaron que se
congelarán las cañerías de su casa a
gstaad stroke cuando acabo de tener un
derrame así que ya sabes cuando dicen
que la electricidad sufrirá
fluctuaciones que vendrá y se irá
nosotros nunca lo vimos nunca tuvimos
dos en torno a 14 millones de personas
cerca de la mitad de habitantes de texas
están sufriendo problemas de agua muchos
no tienen agua de llave y algunos de los
que si la tienen están siendo avisados
de hervirla después de que las plantas
de tratamiento de agua se quedaran sin
energía y otros tienen que tratar con
tuberías rotas e inundaciones con los
estantes de los comercios vacíos
millones de personas dependen de lugares
de distribución como este que despierto
desde las 5 y he estado en la carretera
desde las 6 y sé que son las 11 y media
pero me voy a quedar sentado aquí no
tengo otra opción todas las tiendas de
mi zona se quedaron sin agua la escasez
de agua es sólo el último de una cascada
problemas en texas la inusual tormenta
invernal causó la crisis en el estado
apagando muchas de las redes eléctricas
y dejando a millones sin calefacción
durante días bajo temperaturas heladoras
mientras se espera que las temperaturas
suban este fin de semana el enfado es
alto entre la opinión pública los
funcionarios locales intentan
tranquilizar a la población esta semana
pasada ha sido un gran reto quizás como
ningún otro reto que ya hemos enfrentado
hasta ahora continuaremos trabajando
para abordar y encontrar sus necesidades
y retos para ayudarles a superar el
presidente estadounidense joe biden dijo
el viernes que aprobará la declaración
de desastre en texas allanando el camino
para más ayuda